de nuevo como de suramericana era una
guacamaya bandera que le encantaba estar
volando entre sábanas llanuras bosques e
incluso selvas donde habitaba junto con
su familia todo iba muy bien hasta que
una mañana unos hombres maliciosos
llegaron con unas grandes hachas y con
las mejores palabras convencieron a los
animales de que estos instrumentos
serían netamente para hacer uno que
terreno arreglo en el lugar no tienen
nada de que preocuparse y que mientras
tanto ellos serían recompensados con
unos frutos exóticos y jugosos los
animales acción con entusiasmo
y entonces en ese momento los hombres
aprovecharon para anunciarles de que
también sería colocado un gran manto
negro que cubrirse la selva
todo esto le sonó muy sospechoso al agua
cama de bandera pero al ver que tanto su
familia como los demás animales en el
bosque estaban tan emocionados no le
tomó mucha importancia
como era parte del trato los animales
deberían dejar de cazar y quedarse en
sus casas recibiendo estos frutos
jugosos por parte de los hombres y los
días pasaron y pasaron en pasar hasta
que una mañana dejaron de recibirlos
entonces confundidos deciden salir a
averiguar qué estaba pasando
y en ese momento descubrieron el horror
toda la selva se encontraba destruida
los árboles más preciosos estaban
cortados hasta la raíz y el manto negro
que no había sido muy notorio hasta
entonces limitaba el vuelo de las aves y
secaba los animales
todos entraron en desesperación
e intentaron intentar ahuyentar a estos
hombres lanzando las pocas frutas que
les quedaban en casa pero ya era
demasiado tarde
la familia guacamaya bandera se sentía
muy frustrada ya no había libertad para
volar no había seguridad para los
desplazamientos los alimentos escaseaban
y hermanas y la violencia no permitía
compartir entre la comunidad de aves de
la selva la familia wacom de bandera
tenía que tomar una decisión
no sabían si volar fuera de la selva
quedarse unirse a los malos no tenía ni
idea sólo sabían que algo tenían que
hacer frente a esta situación la familia
guacamaya se ve obligada a tomar una
decisión
salir de la selva quedarse unirse a los
malos no tenía ni idea sólo sabían que
algo tenían que hacer
mostrar de nuevo para guacamaya salieron
a dar un paseo y mientras charlaban
sobre la situación actual de la selva y
de repente divisó en un pequeño haz de
luz que cae desde las desde el manto
negro
extrañados se acerca averiguar qué es y
descubrieron un agujero en el manto
negro
rápidamente voltearon a ver si podemos
salir podemos atravesar este agujero y
salir de la selva
volvieron a su casa muy emocionados a
comentarle a sus hijas lo que habían
descubierto y la decisión que habían
tomado para esto
les comentaron que se habían decidido
salir de la selva volar fuera de la
célula a través de ese agujero la
familia las hermanas guacamayas se
emocionaron mucho y accedieron a
realizar el viaje pero ellos se
aprovecharon y les comentaron de que el
vuelo no sería muy fácil pero que si
mantener una actitud positiva se les
haría más llevadero
esa noche comenzó el viaje para la
familia guacamaya empezaron a arreglar
los preparativos mamá y papá o cama ya
recogieron lo necesario para volar
mientras las hermanas guapa guacamaya a
tomar sus prendas más preciadas
hasta que llegó el gran día
la familia guacamaya se tenía que
preparar con mucha fuerza y mucho valor
para lograr atravesar el agujero negro
el agujero en el manto negro
la idea era que 11 lo intentaron y así
fue
primero el papá o cama ya abrió sus
salas dio unos pasitos hacia atrás tomó
impulso se dio fuerza se lanza y no
logra atravesar mentone grass si no le
tomaron importancia seguir fue mamá o
cama ya hizo lo mismo abrió sus alas dio
unos pasos hacia atrás toma impulso se
lanza y no logra atravesar el montonero
lo mismo hicieron las hermanas guacamaya
pero tampoco lograron atravesarlo esto
los decepcionó bastante
entonces yo no podremos salir de la
selva decía la hermana guacamaya a lo
que vamos como yo le respondía no hay
que perder la esperanza tenemos que
seguir intentándolo no podemos rendirnos
y en ese momento guacamaya bandera se
quedó pensando y dijo
y si lo intentamos en pareja así
seríamos peso no dicho y hecho pero el
primero mamá y papá o cama ya se tomaron
primero de las pruebas dieron unos
pasitos hacia atrás tomaron impulso se
lanzan y no logran atravesar mantenerlo
pero si lograron agrandar el agujero
está funcionando desea muy emocionada la
guacamaya bandera
esto le dio mucha más esperanza y
siguieron intentándolo intentándolo
intentándolo hasta que se cansaron
estaban muy agotadas y decidieron
centrarse los mantenía despiertos el
hecho de volver a ver ese cielo
desplegado la luz del sol en ese momento
la hermana guacamaya levanta la cabeza y
dice que si lo intentamos todos juntos
porque no tenemos mucha fuerza y así
uniremos la poca fortaleza que nos queda
a todos
estudios muy de acuerdo se levantaron se
pusieron en fila se tomaron todos de las
plumas dieron unos pasitos hacia atrás
tomaron impulsos se lanzan
y logran atravesar el manto negro bueno
muy rápido sus alas mueve muy rápido sus
alas desea popa guacamayo meterle
alentado a seguir atravesando el manto
estaban llenas de adrenalina lograron
salir entre tantas emociones tantas
confusiones la familia guacamaya no vio
olvido mirar atrás y esto fue lo mejor
debido a que desde arriba desde el cielo
la amistad de la selva era un gran manto
negro con pequeños agujeros hechos por
otras aves y animales en el bosque
deseando ver la luz del sol
durante el vuelo largo y tedioso la
familia guacamaya siguió dando fuerzas
pero los mantenía despiertos el hecho de
volver a ver ese cielo azul esas nubes
hermosas en ver esa luz del sol ellos no
pensaron en lo que habían perdido sino
en lo que venía buenos libres en
libertad para cazar luz de sol que sólo
se iría cuando llegase la luna
cosas tan básicas o tan simples en la
vida de un ser vivo
que fueron negadas por este hombre y su
gran manto negro
al llegar a tierra firme
la familia guacamaya buscó otra selva en
donde habita y cuando lo consiguieron y
se dieron cuenta que estaba llena de
miles de aves distintas pero eran como
aves hermanas estas las ayudarán a
ubicarse le mostraron la selva y la
familia guacamaya se sintió muy a gusto
y muy agradado
pero no era el momento de descansar
apenas el viaje había empezado el verano
en una vida al empezar desde cero pero
nunca olvidando de dónde viene
aquí terminó la historia era guacamayo
under
interesante nos relata cómo se puede
llegar a complicar la vida de un ser
vivo por causa de intervenciones sobre
su territorio
e intervenciones que pueden llegar a ser
tan fuertes o tan letales que lo
obliguen a volar oa conseguir
una nueva tierra busca nuevos horizontes
y la verdad es que esta es mi historia
mi nombre de larios marchena soy
venezolana y yo soy esa guacamaya que
emigró en busca una nueva vida en busca
de cambiar
estos hombres representan al gobierno un
grupo de personas maliciosas que
llegaron a mi país
con unas grandes hachas con lo que me
quiero referir a la corrupción y con
estas cortaron nuestros árboles más
preciados estos árboles representan la
libertad la paz y la abundancia que eran
tan propios de venezuela
el manto negro fue puesto tanto por el
gobierno como por los diferentes
factores que iban surgiendo pese a esta
situación
situación que se volvió en la lucha de
un día a día
y nos hacía llorar el pasado
nos dimos cuenta muy tarde
pero es que estos frutos tan jugosos que
con lo que me quiero referir a las
regalías por parte del gobierno nos
manteníamos traídos nos llegaban y
cuando dejaron de llegar nos dimos
cuenta de la avalancha que se avecina
ante nosotros
intentamos sacarlos sí pero se nos hizo
imposible que soltara en el poder muchas
almas caídas y otras y lograron
atravesar el manto negro este monto no
es muy fácil de romper se necesita mucha
fuerza y esperanza para lograr realizar
grande o lo suficientemente amplio
para lograr volar y cumplir tus sueños
está guacamaya ha perdido el temor lleno
sus alas de esperanza en sí misma y
fuerza
tomando en cuenta todo su recorrido y lo
que viene me he encontrado con águilas
halcones e incluso otras guacamayas que
me ha ayudado a recalcar la idea de que
todas las aves del mundo deberían ser
libres de surcar otros cielos
pero a veces no es muy fácil hacerlo
solo para esto existen organizaciones
como el acnur que velan y te ayudan
durante este viaje tan difícil este tipo
de organizaciones también me recuerda
que no estamos luchando por un
territorio nacional se trata del mundo
donde vivimos donde muchas tierras se
encuentran ni nada de rencor y egoísmo
dominadas por seres malignos que limitan
el volar de muchas aves que piden a
gritos que se le devuelva su libertad
es nuestro deber como aves mensajeras
eliminar pensamientos xenofóbicos que se
tienen sobre la migración de estas aves
que netamente buscan cambiar para bien
mejorar su vida con el peso de dejar
todo lo que les pertenecía y a todos los
que están acostumbradas es preferible no
mirar atrás no lamentarse y seguir por
este camino o por este viaje que tiene
el potencial de regresarle a todo un
pueblo la esperanza de levantarse en
libertad
[Aplausos]